et has learned a Rosanne revival is  being shopped around our sources say the  revival is still in early discussions  but should the deal close John Goodman  will be a part of it  deadline first reported the news that  Roseanne Barr John Goodman and Sarah  Gilbert will return for the series  Laurie Metcalf and other original cast  members have also reportedly signed on  deadline reports the revival will be  executive produced by the original  series executive producers bar Tom  Werner and Bruce Helford with Gilbert  and Whitney Cummings also on board to  produce ABC and Netflix who found  success with several reboots are  reportedly both bidding on the project  Roseanne ran for nine seasons and was  the most watched show in the u.s. from  1989 to 1990 et has reached out to ABC  and reps for Barr and Gilbert for  comment  [Music]